hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith in today's best picture
close-up let's find out how a harrowing
real-life story became a gripping drama
with director of Paul Greengrass and the
cast of Captain Philipp we knew each
other a little bit but I'd always wanted
to make a film with Tom also there was a
personal thing my my father was in the
Merchant Marine in the 40s and 50s and
spent his life let's see so I felt I
knew something about that world or
rather I didn't know anything about that
world and wanted to know it's a calling
you know it's in something deep inside
them and they tend to be men of few
words they certainly don't cry you know
unless they go through some experience
like this Paula gave sort of a tacit
carte blanche to go figure out
everything go find out everything you
can and on the day of course we'll try
to incorporate as much empirical truth
as we can it's so based on that the
first thing I said to Richard Phillips
when I met him was i'm going to say
things you never said i'm going to do
things you never did that's just the
nature of the compression that must
happen in order to get the story beyond
that comes a version of the of the truth
that you must shoot for so I'm just
hanging out of my friends house and and
then he came on the TV Tom Hanks casting
call Somali actress that's all I needed
to hear but then I was told to that I
cannot edition by myself that I need to
be part of a group so we form our own
group and we didn't do that good the
first day and after night we went home
when we practice and we came back the
second day and we'd be better all four
of them were really good and I had great
group identity they understood that each
of them had a story and they were giving
you that story from the first moment but
it wasn't until the film was together
really that I saw you know the full
weight of what bar kid has done here I
mean he's he's acting opposite in a Tom
and he sustains that because at the
heart of this piece is it's the story of
two captives particularly for rich
Phillips I just found out the incredibly
complicated I call it an algorithm that
was goes on in his head just to run a
ship period much less the new
trigonometry that has to enter into it
when two skiffs appear on the horizon
and those guys have guns then this whole
other thing has to begin Paul just told
me just take control and you know just
do it you know this is your time you
have to take care this scene that's when
I just used a lot of imaginations and
just became the character as much as I
can I became the captain what you're
iming back with a film like this is not
a place where there are easy answer you
don't want sort of one-dimensional
mustache twirling villains but on the
other hand you don't want in any way to
condone or sympathize and justified with
this kind of appalling you know
criminality and what you end up with is
that most dangerous person a young man
with a gun who's got nothing to lose
want to see what happens on Oscar Sunday
visit Oscar com for complete coverage
and look for more inside the Oscar
updates coming soon see you later